[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport sur TV 78 l'émission à ne
surtout pas manquer si vous êtes un
passionné de sport le sport local
étalonneur tout comme les clubs de plus
grands envergure implantés sur notre
territoire et aussi les sportifs
yvelinois qui brillent sur la scène
française voire internationale entourée
de la team vous aurez ici des analyses
techniques des décryptages du débat le
tout dans la bonne humeur nos
chroniqueurs sont motivés comme jamais
en train de préparer en ce moment leur
plus beau summer body on va commencer à
droite musique c'est le capitaine du SOP
ils m'ont tranquillement puissance à
quelques jours du Tour de France comme
Yonas bingorn sur le Critérium du
Dauphiné il a été champion du monde de
cyclisme sur piste master c'est notre
spécialiste vélo mais il s'intéresse à
bien d'autres disciplines Yann Dujarier
est avec nous bonjour Yann comment
allez-vous bonjour Grégory j'ai fait
j'ai fait encore dire bonjour Michael
très très bien très très bien en effet
le Summer body's prépare avec déjà la
marque de la montre ça marque de la
montre marque de bronzage avec ses
entraînements en ce moment en vue de
préparer ce summer body on continue à ma
gauche musique tel un spartiate il
connaît son métier toujours bien placé
dans la mêlée il dit ici chaque sujet
pour un tirer les meilleurs analyses et
les grands détermination font de lui
l'un des maillons forts de cette
émission le guerrier le gladiateur
Pierre Chevalier responsable
communication du Rugby Club de
Versailles avec nous bonjour Pierre fort
du bonheur comment ça va tous salut Greg
salut salut les amis ça va ça va bien
même si on peut dire ça le temps pour
les gros en ce moment comme on dit dans
le bouchon noir mais mais pleine forme
au pluriel pleine forme avec une coupe
du monde de rugby qui approche
l'occasion d'en parler dans cette
émission et on repasse de l'autre côté
musique c'est sans conteste la plus
belle progression de la saison dernière
recrue de cet effectif de champion il a
su se faire une place et gagner ces
galons de titulaire plus plus qu'une
émission avant ça 10e cap nombre de
sport toujours sur les terrains il est
le responsable sponsoring pour orangile
de France c'est bien sûr Philippe volak
qui est avec nous bonjour Philippe
bonjour Greg bonjour la team ça va bien
impeccable dans le dernier ligne droite
avant les vacances et beaucoup beaucoup
d'actualités entre le rugby le foot
surtout ça je veux dire et la finale du
et la finale du Top 14 samedi sans
oublier l'orange Rugby Challenge la
finale nationale avec un club de
Montesson et son château et ça se
déroulera au Centre national du rugby et
avant le soir un tour d'honneur avec
tous les jeunes sur le Stade de France
donc top et on termine en face musique
il n'a raté que la dernière émission
mais qu'il nous a manqué incontournable
comme Antoine Dupont dans le 15 de
France les analyses sont aiguisées c'est
coup de gueule légendaire pas de choix
dans la date si il vous abandon son
viseur garde à vous coach Jean Miss
excentrineur du plaisir Rugby Club avec
nous salut Jean comment ça va bonjour
Grégory bonjour les copains vous êtes
prêts pour l'été alors là et affûté
un bloc
c'est pour ça qu'il est dans les stats
tant mieux alors au menu du jour
messieurs du football bien sûr ça
chauffe au Paris Saint-Germain après une
saison mouvementée les derniers jours le
son tout autant notamment autour du cas
et Kylian Mbappe le FC Versailles
peut-être sauvé du précipice en proie de
grosses difficultés financières le club
de la cité royale pensionnaire de
National a trouvé un nouvel actionnaire
Roland Garros 2023 c'est désormais
terminé un sac historique chez les
hommes notamment pour Novak Djokovic
elle s'est imposée chez les femmes pour
les Français en revanche ça a été
beaucoup moins glorieux mais qu'en
est-il de nos Yves Linois qui étaient
engagés sur la terre battue parisienne
on fera le bilan et puis j moins 86
désormais avant le début de la Coupe du
monde de rugby en France l'engouement
monte progressivement dans les clubs
locaux qui seront pleinement associés à
cette compétition mais pour débuter le
SEP on va prendre tout de suite la
direction de Verneuil-sur-Seine
[Musique]
mercredi 7 juin le terrain d'honneur du
complexe sportif de la ville a été
officiellement inauguré officiellement
rebaptisé surtout au nom de Matteo
Guendouzi alors vous me direz pourquoi
un stade en région parisienne en
l'honneur d'un joueur de l'Olympique de
Marseille et bien kendji est né à Poissy
et c'est bien au Paris Saint-Germain
qu'il a débuté le football pensionnaire
de la préformation du club parisien
l'international français ait été hébergé
à Verneuil et évoluer sur les terrains
de la commune il a même été élève au
collège Jean
Zayn troisième ici au collège et bah sur
ces terrains c'est là où on s'entraînait
pareil pendant trois saisons avec la
avec la préformation donc moi ça avait
ça fait quoi 9-10 ans maintenant donc
pas mal de très bons souvenirs qui qui
reviennent et de la fierté parce que ça
voilà ça ça montre quand même que j'ai
réussi à j'ai réussi à excuser moi à
franchir pas mal de paliers donc à 24
heures avoir un stade à son nom c'est
quand même quelque chose de très beau et
j'en suis vraiment très fier
une après-midi dont les jeunes du club
vernolien se souviendront encore
longtemps Matteo gaines Douzi assisté à
leur entraînement pendant une petite
heure l'occasion est d'échanger avec les
footballeurs en herbe et de se prêter
ensuite à l'exercice de la séance de
dédicace c'est un très bel hommage
effectivement pour pour le club pour
lui-même avoir son monde dans son club
d'origine c'est c'est exceptionnel il
m'a sauté plein de bien pour l'avenir
bien travailler à l'école et de
continuer le foot ça me plaît
franchement j'ai été ému c'était quelque
chose que je pense qu'il va marquer
toute ma vie et franchement ça a été un
moment incroyable parce que tu les vois
avec le sourire tu les vois avec la
banane je les ai vu ce matin au collège
aussi c'était vraiment tous heureux donc
c'est c'est s'ils peuvent avoir des
exemples pas que moi mais d'autres mais
d'autres joueurs ou d'autres personnes
c'est vraiment quelque chose de beau
pour pour les aider à réussir dans dans
le futur
et le footballeur également reçu la
médaille de la ville la municipalité a
souhait ainsi valoriser le parcours de
ce jeune vernolien un terrain à son nom
à seulement 24 ans c'est un bel hommage
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez Yann
ou c'est trop tôt peut-être encore
je trouve que enfin alors je pense que
c'est un véritable honneur et dans le
parallèle je vois la fierté que Florent
François Pervis peut avoir d'avoir un
vélo Drôme le vélodrome de Limoges qui
porte son nom je crois que c'est celui
de Limoges non pas de Limoges dans la
Sarthe il a un vélo drone qui porte son
nom et c'est vrai qu'il en est il en est
particulièrement fier
ça je peux et je peux le couper
l'entendre 24 ans bon oui euh maintenant
Verneuil n'aura peut-être pas beaucoup
d'autres
voleurs de ce de ce calibre parce que
Ben maternité bengousier quand même
international français donc bah on va on
va dire tant mieux pour lui j'espère que
c'est du portera pas la poisse comme ça
pue la porter à
non un joueur français à l'international
français qui jouait en Angleterre et qui
a eu des condamnations pour viol je
retrouve pas son nom
et qui avait un nom ce qui avait son son
terrain d'honneur à Palaiseau et son nom
était enlevé donc bon on va espérer
qu'il est pas de mauvaises affaires par
la suite Philippe qu'en pensez-vous vous
avez été vous sur place pour Orange
d'ailleurs parce que vous étiez
partenaire de l'événement est-ce qu'on a
monté des commandes des ateliers
numériques sur le cyber-harcèlement avec
une centaine de gamins donc c'était top
moi j'ai trouvé que c'était c'était bien
pour les gamins pour la ville en plus le
matin il faut il y a pas eu que le
terrain il a été au collège il a revu il
a revu sa prof anglais et tout qui lui a
parlé comme il a été Arsenal avant et
tout ça en commun
il y a eu un clin d'oeil en sortant du
collège qu'ils ont les jeunes se sont
mis on dit ici c'est Paris mais
j'ai trouvé j'ai en plus il était il a
pris le temps moi j'ai été depuis 13h
l'après-midi il a pris le temps et il a
comment je dire il a il apparaît tous
les gamins il a pris les photos il a
fait une séance de dédicace il est resté
longtemps et ouais ça a été très
apprécié ça a été très apprécié
disponible également pour la presse très
facilement à notre micro je voyais
réagir genre disponible c'était la
moindre des choses selon vous
bon juste très bien pour lui j'aurais eu
pas le dessus pour lui maintenant je
pense que lorsqu'on donne
le nom un stade ou une enceinte sportive
un peu plus de de
lui
dans la communication
que ça c'est la première liste
tant mieux mais tant mieux pour lui
c'est bien tiens plutôt étonné au départ
par pour trois raisons la première c'est
sous l'âge on a plus l'habitude de de
donner des des noms de stade lors des
Loges funèbres par exemple en hommage en
hommage par exemple deuxièmement c'est
c'est par son par son oracle qui qui par
rapport à d'autres footballeurs de sa
génération et peut-être un petit peu
plus limité certes il joue à l'OM certes
il est il est international
mais voilà mais pour cette coupe du
monde là justement il n'a pas beaucoup
joué il était avec les coiffeurs et euh
très bien avec sa coupe de cheveux
d'ailleurs aussi mais c'est en gros
c'est il a encore une aura qui est
peut-être peut-être encore un petit peu
limité sur la scène
internationale pas national mais
international et troisièmement par son
par son pedigree il a eu sa première
licence au PSG et il est maintenant à
l'OM c'est un jeu ça c'est un joli clin
d'oeil un joli clin d'œil sportif et de
marketing bon en tout cas je pense que
si la ville de Verneuil a choisi de lui
de lui décerner un nom de Stade c'est
qu'a priori il y aura peut-être pas
forcément beaucoup de noms après coup
émergents de Verneuil et que et que
c'est quand même ça reste quand même un
international et a priori un garçon
plein d'avenir pour le football français
voilà
c'est l'occasion de lui poser quelques
questions sur son avenir il a été flou
effectivement annoncé en partance de
l'OM avec notamment des pistes qui se
dessine en première ligue Aston Villa
mais également Newcastle aussi la
Juventus et l'Inter en Italie vous avez
des préférences Italie Première League
non mais nous on va rester calme
et puis
le championnat anglais ça
et puis en plus des clubs qui ont moins
de prestige que que les mais il va
peut-être rester aussi le nouvel
entraîneur par rapport au Nouvel An de
possibilités il y a aussi une
incertitude liée effectivement à la
suite d'Igor tu dors qui n'est plus lui
l'entraîneur du Paris Saint-Germain on
va passer à présent à notre du Paris
Saint-Germain de l'Olympique de
Marseille et on va parler justement du
Paris Saint-Germain dans notre page
débat
[Musique]
oui puisque son avenir à lui est aussi
en pointillé dans son club Killian
Mbappé n'est pas sûr justement de rester
au Paris Saint-Germain cette fois-ci
j'ai le bon club elle attaquant à
adresser un courrier à sa direction le
12 juin courrier rendu public dans
celui-ci le précise qu'il ne lèvera pas
l'option l'option pour rester une saison
supplémentaire au Paris Saint-Germain
jusqu'en 2025 il pourra donc partir
libre à la fin de son contrat dans un an
à l'été 2024 il n'en fallait pas moins
pour agiter les rumeurs de départ qu'il
envoie dès cet été au Real Madrid qui
vient de voir en plus partir un certain
Karim Benzema mensonge répond le
principal intéressé sur Twitter en
affirmant vouloir honorer sa dernière
année de contrat et continuer avec le
Paris Saint-Germain la saison prochaine
et du côté du PSG la direction n'aurait
pas du tout apprécié le courrier Demba P
les dirigeants en entendent pas le
laisser partir gratuitement dans un an
et réfléchissent sérieusement à
l'hypothèse de le vendre dès ce mercato
estivale Mbappé lui a justifié sa
position dans un communiqué transmis à
nos confrères de l'AFP à l'international
indique n'avoir jamais discuté d'une
possibilité de prolongation avec le
Paris Saint-Germain au-delà de 2024 et
ce courrier avait pour seul objectif de
préciser de confirmer ce qu'il y avait
déjà été précisé à l'oral au préalable
la question sur ce thème qui a raison
dans ce bras de fer alors code couleur
vous votez vert pour Mbappé rouge pour
le Paris Saint-Germain qui a raison dans
ce bras de fer selon vous
vers pour Mbappé rouge pour le Paris
Saint-Germain là on est plutôt sur du
Mbappe et là du mitigé donc on va faire
un duel entre Pierre et Philippe pour
commencer justement vous étiez vous
plutôt du côté de Mbappé pourquoi c'est
Mbappé qui a raison dans ce bras de fer
Philippe parce qu'il a raison parce que
il est très bon comme il l'a pas fait il
l'a pas fait comme ça il a pas envoyé
son courrier comme ça il l'a fait juste
après que allande en plus vient de
gagner la Champions League c'est qu'il a
un peu en concurrence Manchester City
Benzema qui est parti je pense que
c'était le moment propice pour faire son
coup de com et je pense qu'il est il
était il est il est très bon niveau au
niveau campus sec de toute façon il est
tient il tient le club il tient le club
lui de toute façon donc voilà
Killian Saint-Germain ou le Mbappe
Saint-Germain c'est exactement ça et il
y a peut-être aussi par rapport au mois
je pense aussi peut-être par rapport à
compo ce souci je me dis il y a
peut-être quelque chose derrière parce
que le directeur sportif il y a
peut-être un quelque chose aussi
derrière pour voilà et voir aussi
peut-être mettre un coup de pression
aussi sur le recrutement qui va arriver
l'entraîneur qui va arriver qu'on sait
pas encore il y a des rumeurs mais voilà
je pense que il est très bon comme et en
général il se trompe jamais dans la com
il sait quand le quant au pelacom alors
vous étiez plutôt mitigé sur qui a
raison dans ce dans ce bras de fer
Philippe dit un coup de com de la part
de Mbappé sans doute sans aucun doute
parce que pour ajouter à ce que disait
Philippe sur le personnage qui est
Mbappe c'est un c'est une une star
internationale planétaire du football
qui réfléchit c'est c'est là où il a il
a il a un pedigree AC assez différent
d'un Benzema ou ou de ou même aussi bon
pour rester au PSG
c'est toujours réfléchi et tous les tous
les toutes les sorties qu'il y a eu et
de communication notamment quand il
s'agissait de son image à travers des
partenaires et des sponsors quand il
s'agit aussi de son image au niveau
internet
avec l'équipe de France ou avec le PSG
c'est toujours très mesuré c'est
toujours très réfléchi il est bien
entouré bien conseillé ce qui me fait
hésiter ce qui est sur les
responsabilités c'est que depuis le
début depuis son arrivée à Paris c'est
un feuilleton arrondissement
Mbappe au PSG il a pris il a pris une
place indispensable et prépondérante
puisque c'est lui qui fait la saison
dernière c'est-à-dire qu'en gros même
ceux qui y sont qui ont des
responsabilités qui passent au PSG ne
résiste pas à la longévité et à
l'influence de Kylian Mbappe exemple
Christophe Galtier pour nous citer que
lui sur les sur les véhicules sur les
récents sur les récents d'épisodes sans
Mbappe sur la saison dernière et
d'ailleurs même sur toutes les saisons
le PSG n'est pas au même niveau il gagne
que un titre de champion de France je
mets des gros guillemets à queue parce
que c'est comme ça reste quand même un
type de champion de France et de Ligue 1
mais c'est le énième du PSG et quasiment
de suite avec le PSG premier dans
l'histoire un remporté mon style en
Ligue 1 c'est quand même un coup de
chapeau à tous ceux qui ont été
impliqués là-dedans néanmoins il y a il
y a aussi dans ce coup de com il y a une
inversion de la pression et de dire que
c'est aussi une querelle de grosses ou
un an avant l'échéance donc premièrement
là où je n'hésite pas c'est que Mbappé
est droit dans ses bottes il confirme ce
qu'il avait déjà dit les années
précédentes et dans la gestion de son
contrat mais que on est on est un an
dans la possibilité en fait que le PSG
puisse récolter du fruit
financier de d'un transfert de Mbappé si
ça a intervenait cet été ou ou pendant
l'année si ça ne bouge pas 2024 il part
libre de tous les livres de contrat et
là et ce que veut éviter le PSG parce
que là c'est pour le coup c'est un
investissement en dehors du sportif
c'est un investissement perdants donc
c'est je dirais l'hésitation elle vient
de l'ensemble de l'équipe du PSG pas
forcément de Nasser uniquement ou de
compost mais c'est de tout ceux qui sont
impliqués côté PSG dans la gestion des
renouvellements de contrats là pour
l'instant ils ont été pris de cours donc
c'est là où peut-être le timing le
timing et soumise
parce que la pression est mise sur eux
donc en gros c'est une c'est là c'est là
où j'hésite c'est que c'est que il y a
une responsabilité de Kylian Mbappé sur
le sur le timing choisi et
maintenant il va falloir se retourner
pour le PSG et construire devant la
saison prochaine a commencé par un
entraîneur puis après puis après un
effectif qui selon leur dire à eux
disent on peut continuer à construire
sans qu'il y a la même baptême
sportivement là je demande à voir parce
que il a quand même prouvé le contraire
depuis si c'est juste à rajouter juste
une chose et sachant qu'il était pas
obligé de faire ce courrier puisque de
toute façon il a jusqu'au 31 juillet
pour
on a l'impression dans cette affaire
gens que on ne quitte pas le PSG c'est
plutôt le PSG qui vous congés dit parce
que on ne supporte pas un éventuel
départ côté des remparts
mes camarades ont dit mais peut-être que
le voit comme ça mais lui il a quand
même en position de force donc si elle a
un des deux qui est positionné force
c'est bien quand même Mbappé qui lui a
les meilleures cartes en main moi je dis
simplement je rajouterai parce que tout
a été tout a été quasi vanille je
rajouterais juste une petite chose c'est
ce que j'espère que ce feuilleton là va
pas nous prendre tous les thés comme
l'an dernier ou euh
mais moi moi ça ça voilà ça ça s'amuse
ça ça voilà ça je suis un peu mais bon
sinon et donc arrivé ça assez rapidement
là et puis comme ça c'est bon parce que
là si c'est pour noircir du du de la
feuille de chou c'est bon mais
pour aller un peu dans votre sens
Gregory je pense que ça va pas seulement
l'été mais je pense que ça va être toute
l'année prochaine où ça risque de
discuter à plusieurs périodes pour
justement essayer de conserver Kylian
avant la avant la fin avant la fin du
contrat mais quand on dit qu'il a fait
le PSG cette saison 43 matchs 41 buts 9
passes décisives c'est dire toute
l'importance collectif mais meilleur
buteur du championnat encore une fois
mais enfin voilà non il y a pas de c'est
lui qui fait le club il fait tout il
fait c'est lui qui fait ouais
international en plus il est tout aussi
indispensable maintenant capitaine de
l'équipe de France donc il a il a une il
a une aura il a une aura une influence
sur le football français en club et en
équipe de France qui est qui est qui est
indispensable
il va avoir 25 ans effectivement dans
dans quelques mois alors
est-ce qu'ils ont peur aussi c'est qu'il
y a la renouvellement des droits TV
en septembre-octobre et ça peut prendre
un coup s'il y a 100 mètres
chacun fait ce qu'il veut
Léo c'est l'histoire du football il a
marqué cette histoire
je pense que c'est le meilleur au monde
et donc je lui souhaite le meilleur
après il est normal que les supporters
ne soient pas tellement heureux après
cette saison
il nous les comprenons car nous avons
perdu un peu trop de matchs et ça ce
n'est pas bien
il faut nous améliorer et aller de
l'avant essayez de faire mieux l'an
prochain et se fixer des objectifs
importants
il n'a pas eu le respect qu'il méritait
c'est même la phrase dit aujourd'hui par
Kylian Mbappé un qui a donné une
interview au journal italien de la
Gazzetta dello sports mais si c'est plus
Ballon d'Or s'en va sans avoir brillé
n'était pas heureux à Paris il a
affirmait aussi dans les médias
espagnols la Pulga va jouer à l'Inter
Miami en MLS il y a aussi on rajoute le
départ de Christophe Galtier pierre en
parler seulement après une saison à une
saison seulement après son arrivée sur
le banc parisien souvient aussi de la
manifestation des supporters contre
Neymar devant sa demeure à Bougival les
incertitudes liées aussi à l'avenir du
Paris-Saint-Germain dans le Parc des
Princes autre question que j'ai envie de
vous poser sur sur cette thématique la
saison du PSG et ce qu'il y a votre avis
ce n'est pas la pire saison depuis
l'arrivée des qatari au Paris
Saint-Germain
parce que certes il y a des résultats
sportifs mais en coulisses quand même ça
a beaucoup chauffé cette année
alors on a dû oui pour Jean pour Jean
oui et du et du nom pour Yann et ben on
va faire un duel entre vous deux
messieurs et on va commencer avec Jean
oui pourquoi pourquoi le PSG vit-il
peut-être ça pire saison depuis
l'arrivée des guitaristes déjà tout
simplement parce qu'ils ont quasi le
titre je suis le champion de France et
riquera qui a un point pourquoi c'est
quoi le deuxième la commande le Trophée
des champions ça compte pour ça
Mickey
non mais et puis à un point seulement de
de lance quoi avec les avec les moyens
qui qui atteinettent les joueurs de
prestige qu'ils ont finir certes c'est
un record 11 de titre champion de on n'y
revient pas mais quand même on s'attend
et il s'attendent eux-mêmes à beaucoup
plus quoi qu'une équipe comme ça qui est
simplement
une fois très juste très très juste et
puis le une fois de plus à catastrophe
en Ligue des Champions et
une grosse problématique à garder un
effectif stable quoi stable avec c'est
toujours on sait que c'est le PSG ça
fait parler beaucoup mais là mais vu
clairement un prêt poste Coupe du Monde
il y a peut-être aussi la Coupe du Monde
qui a beaucoup influé sur cette saison
oui mais bon moi pour moi ça a été ça a
été la pire et je leur souhaite de
redresser et de redresser la barre et
peut-être de revoir un petit peu leur
effectif avec des gens qui ont envie de
mouiller le maillot alors pourquoi non
ça n'a pas été la pierre Yann on a quand
même l'impression qu'il y a quelque
chose qui s'est brisé entre les
supporters et le Paris Saint-Germain
vous avez aborder le sujet la Coupe du
monde n'a pas fait n'a pas fait du bien
à beaucoup de à beaucoup de clubs ça a
été difficile de gérer je pense que
Neymar a toujours du mal à se remettre
de la de la défaite
ça a pu aussi créer des tensions avec la
victoire de Messi pourquoi moi j'ai
juste dit non parce que faut pas oublier
que depuis l'air qatary il y a eu des
saisons où ils ont pas gagné le titre de
champion de France voilà donc là il
gagne utile de champ de France donc
c'est pas pire que de ne pas gagner le
titre de champion la première saison
avec Monaco et plus récemment avec
Montpellier et plus récemment avec
Monaco il y avait pas eu un île aussi
en 2021 il y a aussi un lit un livre
dans l'histoire donc du coup pour moi
c'est pas la pire maintenant en effet
avec le avec l'effectif comme l'a dit
non on s'attendait à beaucoup beaucoup
mieux et on se disait surtout c'était la
deuxième saison avec avec Messi s'ils
sont les plus loin beaucoup plus loin en
Ligue des Champions
elle est facilement
c'est pareil tirage au sort on tombe
contre contre
Real Madrid contre le Bayern Munich
va aussi en finale avec Didier Deschamps
c'était je sais plus quel le sait pas en
voilà mais c'est pareil Monaco avait eu
le tirage au sort pour les clubs
français et hyper important dans un
parcours en Coupe d'Europe je dirais je
dirais que que c'est la pire en termes
de manière la manière que que l'esprit
global que le que cette équipe avait
véhiculé cette saison là était assez
triste
l'exemple le plus dingue c'est c'est la
fin de saison de Messi qui marchait
puisqu'il me courait sur le terrain et
globalement une saison où on a parlé
beaucoup plus extra sportif que le
sportif et on a perdu le fil d'entrée et
il y avait déjà ces négociations en
coulisses il y avait déjà ce désamour de
Neymar de même de Messi mais un messie
légende du sport du foot qui se fait
siffler comme ça et quand même les
supporters en gros je pense
pour nous c'est à dire que la
célébration du titre au parc c'était a
priori d'une tristesse absolue
c'est-à-dire qu'en gros
il y avait beaucoup de feux d'artifice
effectivement il y avait pas il y avait
pas d'engouement donc encore une fois de
dire que que la manière et l'esprit n'y
était pas et en gros l'envie l'envie non
plus donc
tournons cette page là on sait pas trop
où on va que ce soit de de l'entraîneur
jusqu'à l'équipe jusqu'à l'effectif
est-ce qu'ils vont remettre un petit peu
d'esprit parisien dans cette équipe
plutôt que d'aligner les stars c'est au
dire de la plupart des fans du PSG et
des spécialistes c'est la solution pour
que le PSG retrouve une âme et peut-être
aille enfin chercher son Graal en
Champions League le fait notable sur ce
match face à Clermont c'était l'hommage
aussi à sergio Rico qui a été victime
d'un accident de de cheval en Espagne et
match perdus match perdu
et c'est honneur c'est honneur c'est
faire honneur à Clermont que de le
rappeler mais ils sont quand même ils
sont gagnés trois deux en
déjà débuté en coulisses pour trouver le
nouvel entraîneur pour prendre la suite
de Christophe Galtier de nouvelles
recrues le PSG qui recommencera
officiellement sa saison dès le début du
mois d'août avec le Trophée des
Champions face à Toulouse vainqueur de
la Coupe de France une rencontre qui est
programmée le 5 août pour l'instant
c'est toujours maintenu qui me fait non
mais pour l'instant c'est toujours
maintenu même s'il y a beaucoup
d'incertitude en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que ça ne se jouera pas en
Thaïlande mais peut-être que la date du
5 août sera bien maintenue pour cette
date du Trophée des Champions la date du
5 août qui est bien sûr peut-être
maintenant on verra on verra par la
suite on va continuer de parler football
et cette bonne nouvelle pour le football
club de Versailles en proie à
d'importantes difficultés financières le
club de National un nouvel actionnaire
majoritaire l'équipe yvinoise va être
reprise par Alexandre Mulliez ex
vice-président d'Auchan retail France et
petit-fils du fondateur du groupe Auchan
Gérard Mulliez il va investir près de 3
millions d'euros il sera épaulé de son
bras droit Fabien Lazare tous les deux
devraient occuper des fonctions
opérationnelles au sein du club Julien
ridon et Christophe petit patron groupe
fidu SimCity qui était à la tête du club
depuis 2021 vont eux rester au conseil
d'administration et le club auteur d'une
fin de saison compliquée avec une
cinquième place au classement à 11
points de la montée devrait donc
échapper une relégation administrative
une audition a eu lieu le 6 juin devant
la DNCG le gendarme financier du foot
l'adncg semble avoir apprécié l'arrivée
d'un nouvel actionnaire mais ce n'est
pas encore ne s'est pas encore prononcé
sur la saison prochaine la question sur
cette thématique tout simplement est-ce
que l'horizon s'éclaircit pour le
football club de Versailles
il y a un grand oui et on va débuter
cette fois-ci avec avec vous Yann bah
pourquoi pour vous l'horizon s'éclaircit
pour le football club de Versailles
alors moi je
sais pas oui de toute façon vous avez un
nouvel investisseur vous avez 3 millions
tant mieux mais ça va c'est pas encore
totalement prononcé sur le sort du FC
Barcel pareil on ne sait toujours pas si
Victor bengama ira au sport ou pas donc
tant que c'est pas signé ce n'est pas
fait on est d'accord mais voilà là il y
a quand même un point financier un
quelque chose qui on est on est loin de
la zone de relégable maintenant moi ce
que je ce que je voulais surtout dire
sur ce sur ce sujet c'est qu'il le
mérite voilà depuis deux saisons par le
deux avec des beaux parcours avec des
des
ils ont traversé beaucoup de difficultés
si ça pouvait aller un petit peu mieux
c'est à dire avoir moins d'extraps
sportifs et n'avoir que du que du
positif peut-être que sur le terrain on
sent alors on va pas dire sentir la
différence parce que il venait de monter
et ils ont joué le temps le tableau
premier surtout que la première moitié
de saison ils ont joué longtemps le
tableau bon là on se retrouve avec on
finit sur une cinquième place on l'avait
dit déjà dès le début de fin dès le
début de saison ce serait juste bien de
se maintenir faut pas brûler les étapes
faut pas oublier que bah ils peuvent pas
jouer à domicile si jamais il continue
de monter déjà dans ce dans ce niveau de
division c'est difficile de jouer à
domicile donc là il faut il faut rester
construire et voilà essayer de d'éviter
le
stress sportifs qui qui peut pourrir
aussi bien le PSG comment vous en parler
on a fait souvent le parallèle entre le
Paris-Saint-Germain et le FC Versailles
bon des clubs d'une dimension totalement
différente mais c'est vrai qu'on lisse
ça a été compliqué un petit peu
compliqué pour un petit pas pour un club
de niveau nation au final en effet on a
quand même beaucoup parlé eux dans les
faits divers et pas pas toujours des
choses à agréables voilà donc il faut un
peu de sérénité je pense que ça fera du
bien à tout le monde c'est vrai qu'il y
a de gros contrats assumé pierre il y a
quand même 11 joueurs qui se sous
contrat dans cet effectif professionnel
il y a 8 joueurs qui ont un salaire
supérieur à 9000 euros donc ils vont
falloir qu'il rééquilibre un petit peu
tout ça pour un club de National c'est
c'est effectivement une masse sale qui
est qui est assez importante
sauvé on va dire oui parce que
l'investisseur qui arrive est crédible
et notamment la famille la famille et
les groupes qui sont derrière d'une
manière ou d'une autre sont sont solides
sont solides et costaud il y a un petit
mais ou un gros nez c'est qu'on a
toujours le même problème structurel sur
la ville de Versailles et sur pour le
football concernant le stade et ça ça
restera le le gros caillou dans la dans
la chaussure de ce club dans les
crampons de du FC Versailles on rappelle
que le stade n'est pas homologué en tout
cas l'éclairage des homologué pour jouer
pour jouer alors déjà en National et en
ce moment en Ligue 2 et du coup ils ont
joué cette année on le voit au stade
Jean-Bouin et même sur la fin d'année
ils n'ont même pas pu assumer le loyer
du stade Jean-Bouin et ont dû s'exiler
sur la fin de saison du côté de
Saint-Gratien voilà et donc c'est le
c'est là où le blé c'est que il y a
justement cette cette impossibilité de
jouer sur la ville de Versailles dans un
stade de la ville de Versailles et ça
sera ça un vrai problème posé que que
n'importe quel million ne pourra pas
forcément régler puisque c'est c'est un
c'est un problème culturel architectural
qu'il faudra qu'il faudra contourner
d'une manière ou d'une autre alors soit
avec des autorisations pour que les
mains finalement soit soit autorisés au
stade de Montbauron notamment ou alors
trouver autre chose mais pour bien pour
bien le connaître il y a pas il y a pas
des masses de d'infrastructure sportive
à Versailles qui sont capables
d'accueillir une équipe de une équipe
professionnelle en National je
terminerai simplement en rappelant que
pour reparler du sportif qui
effectivement la saison la saison du FCV
a finalement été dans les clous on a on
a rêvé beaucoup à plus grand mais
finalement là toute proportion gardée
c'est soyons raisonnable voyons que ils
se sont maintenus ils ont terminé dans
le top 10 donc même top 5 top 5 sur
cette saison cette première saison
nationale donc voilà c'était compliqué
il y avait 6 décembre attendons
attendons la suite avec peut-être un
petit peu un tout petit peu d'inquiétude
sur le coup de le fonctionnement
structurel au moins sur la partie
financière on a un petit peu plus de
garantie ouais quick du stade quid du
staff aussi puisque il n'y a plus à ce
jour de Responsable Recrutement plus
d'entraîneurs le Brésilien Christ qui
avait remplacé en cours de saison
Youssef chibi on le rappelle condamné à
8 mois de prison avec sursis pour avoir
filmé des femmes à leur insu à
officialiser son départ dès la fin du
championnat national il y a des dossiers
chauds à régler tout de même Philippe
pour le FC Versailles c'est pour ça que
je pose la question est-ce que l'horizon
s'éclaircisse parce que déjà le dossier
chaud c'était la reprise j'étais comme
pessimiste on en a parlé à la dernière
émission même les autres émissions
j'étais quand même pessimiste au niveau
sportif heureusement qu'ils ont fait
aussi une bonne première partie puisque
ils sont dit qu'ils sont à 11 points du
premier mais ils sont à 11 points du
premier relais
au milieu et c'était tellement serré que
voilà donc comme Nancy par exemple qui
descend en National de voilà qui descend
bon je pense que voilà faut attendre
qu'ils passent devant l'adncg comme
d'autres clubs sera quand même beaucoup
bouger et pas quand Pâques en National
en Ligue 2 aussi mais voilà maintenant
je pense que on attend adncg après il va
avoir l'entrée l'entraîneur le routeur
je pense que voilà je pense qu'il
repartent sur de je pense qu'ils vont
partir sur de bonnes bases et puis voilà
il y aura l'année prochaine ce sera
moins difficile et
parce que on sait qu'il va investir
voilà on attend toutes les
officialisations et aussi peut-être
qu'il s'exprime sur le projet du club
est-ce qu'il y aura aussi d'ores et déjà
des objectifs de remonter tout de suite
de monter tout de suite en Ligue 2 comme
ça avait été le cas la saison dernière
on est en attente genre votre avis sur
le sujet
Versailles énormément parlé suite alors
fabuleux parcours un coup de France
allant jusqu'en demi-finale donc ça
avait ça avait éclaté on ne parlait que
de Versailles sportivement avec que du
bonus du plus c'était excellent parcours
un groupe de France c'était une montée
en National magnifique et avec en plus
on l'a dit tout à l'heure une première
partie du championnat est insolente et
qui voyait éventuellement des des
un futur proche peut-être merveilleux
jusqu'à en Ligue 2 et puis on le sait
aussi on le sait toujours c'est l'argent
qui fait quand même beaucoup beaucoup de
choses dans le milieu professionnel
surtout au football on parle beaucoup et
là ça ça le carburant on avance pas donc
là après mais on ils ont ils ont eu
toutes les péripéties qu'on connaît
qu'on a
redit autour de cette table et le fait
pour moi que il y a un investisseur qui
arrive
d'autant plus sérieux a fait humilier
qui a quand même des garanties va
certainement leur permettre de repartir
sur un esprit plus tranquille et avec
d'une bonne lucidité pour repartir sur
une saison et qu'on reparle de
Versailles sportivement et non pas avec
toutes les déboires qui leur sont
arrivés ces derniers temps on va suivre
bien sûr la situation prête très
rapidement juste pour bien le parcours
de Coupe de France il était beau mais il
avait été compliqué aussi quand même
au niveau de la des NCG alors au niveau
de la DC on devrait en savoir un peu
plus dans dans les prochains jours on va
suivre la situation de prêt tout comme
celle d'un autre club des Yvelines là il
faut aussi on le disait qu'il a été
relégué en National 2 de National 2 au
niveau régional à cause de problèmes
financier et d'une dette de 260000 euros
on a déjà la date en tout cas pour les
Poissy qui sera fixé sur son appel le 4
juillet prochain date de l'audition
devant la commission d'appel de la DNCG
dans les locaux de la Fédération
française de football on parle tennis à
présent messieurs Roland Garros c'est
terminé après deux semaines de
compétition même 3 ainsi on inclut
également les qualifications le tournoi
du Grand Chelem c'est achevé le 11 juin
dernier la Polonaise IGAS viatech l'a
emporté chez les femmes contre la
tchèques muchova et Novak Djokovic lui
s'est imposé chez les hommes en dominant
le Norvégien roude en 3.7 le cerf
devient aussi le recordman de victoire
en Grand Chelem avec 23 titres il
dépasse Raphaël Nadal ça vous inspire
quoi très rapidement déjà sur la
victoire de Novak Djokovic en un mot
respect total magnifique magnifique
contrôle en plus même si même si il a il
a une personnalité qui est qui est un
petit peu voilà qui est pas toujours qui
est pas toujours apprécié par le grand
public mais là je crois qu'on peut en
eau on ne doit on ne doit que c'est un
mot discours et en français
et mais on ne peut que s'incliner devant
cette cette performance de très haut vol
très rapidement j'ai pas vu les j'ai pas
vu le dernier match donc parce qu'il a
quand même eu un peu des difficultés
même sur la première semaine enfin moi
en plus Roland Garros s'est arrêté le
premier jeu hein jeudi 1er juin pour moi
c'était fini mes enfants étaient plus
intéressés on a pu regarder les matchs
non mais respect même Nadal l'a dit
Nadal et il a été très inspectueux avec
lui après aussi c'est quand même c'est
après son se passe après c'est grands
joueurs et non c'est bravo
de ces exploits ce Nadal aussi se fait
derrière on a quand même on a du beau
monde on a du beau monde il aurait pu
enfin aussi fort sens ces deux autres
joueurs je pense qu'il en aura enfilé
encore beaucoup plus mais là il y a
quand même eu des années où ils se sont
battus à trois là et c'était des sacré
Triel des beaux duels à chaque fois des
beaux des beaux matchs donc oui on peut
être que respectueux et admiratif du
travail de Djokovic tout à fait il y
avait aussi deux saint-germain-nois en
lice a commencé par Caroline Garcia
celle qui nous a fait vibrer la saison
dernière après une victoire au premier
tour contre la Chinoise see you
livinoise c'est incliné et dès le
deuxième tour contre la rue Sana
blinkova défaite en 3 7 6 4 3 6 5 7
pourtant bien lancer la numéro en
française a connu un passage à vide
fatal dans le deuxième set 22 fautes
direct à la concédé 5 jeux d'affilée et
pour la troisième année de suite
élimination donc dès le deuxième tour à
la Porte d'Auteuil il est quand même
repassé quatrième mondial c'est à
signalé après Roland Garros c'est ce
qu'on peut parler forcément de mauvais
bilan pour vous oui ou non clairement au
niveau français pour Caroline bien sûr
en plus quand on entend l'interview
après le premier match j'ai retrouvé mon
niveau de jeu j'ai ça fait longtemps que
j'ai pas joué aussi bien je me souviens
et du plaisir à jouer voilà l'interview
à la fin du on se dit du gaz du super
espoir aussi je pense qu'elle avait tous
les espoirs sur Roland Garros reposer
sur elle aussi après son année
incroyable
on pensait que c'était il y avait
quelques jours
ou trois semaines on sait pas trop
tromper sur les pronostics on avait dit
c'était chez les dames Garcia le plus
loin
deuxième tour il y a une darknès chez
les hommes voilà bon c'est pas trop
parce qu'il a il a pris en français
c'est souvent comme ça c'est quand tu as
une autre voiture qui est un deuxième
fraction 2e dommage que de l'autre côté
il est pas là parce que il aurait pu
tomber aussi contre un français au
deuxième tour c'est dommage que ça c'est
pas surpris finalement sur l'élimination
de thyroline Garcia ah c'est quand même
merci
surprise
bien sûr en plus ouais le premier match
c'est vrai qu'elle avait vraiment bien
joué et puis quand on entend des voilà
enfin ce que j'ai dit ouais en plus
et enfin ouais une grosse grosse
déception tout simplement quoi après son
année on le rappelle incroyable en 2022
un quatre titres dont le master WTA
alors vous en avez parlé vous m'avez
précédé mais l'autre jour originaire
Saint-Germain-en-Laye c'est dans le
tableau homme Arthur rinderknech qui est
disputé qui disputait à 27 ans déjà son
quatrième Roland-Garros le joueur a pour
la première fois de sa carrière atteint
le deuxième tour du tournoi pour se
faire il a battu au premier tour un
Français Richard Gasquet duel donc
franco-français le match c'est déroulé
dans une très une ambiance sur le cours
Suzanne Lenglen plutôt acquis il faut le
dire à la cause de Richard Gasquet
succès en 4,7 6 4 2 6 6 2 7 6 et puis au
deuxième tour le 78e mondial avait face
à lui la tête de série numéro 9 Taylor
Swift et la hiérarchie était respectée
des fêtes en 4 7 6 2 4 6 3 6 4 6 il a
pourtant longtemps fait jeu égal avec
l'américain remportant le premier set
avec un très bon service avant que son
adversaire ne reprenne le dessus bon
deuxième tour ok pas de pas de français
au troisième tour mais sur Arthur hinder
cneche est-ce qu'on peut parler de bon
bilan ou pas ça progresse ça progresse
ça progresse c'est c'est ce qu'il faut
retenir
qu'en gros c'est cette opposition
notamment celle contre Fritz et une est
un belle promesse d'avril d'avenir
c'est c'est quand même un sacré client
en face il lui prend le premier set et
derrière c'est une ça va faire partie
des défaites encourageantes quoi donc ce
pays oui ça progresse petitement et ça
progresse c'est son maximum le deuxième
tour dans un tournoi du Grand Chelem il
a fait à deux reprises à l'US Open et
aussi à l'Open d'Australie Jean votre
avis
petitement on va dire c'est vrai qu'il
fait quasiment le jeu égal on va dire si
il est sur 4 7 gagne le premier 6-2 il
perd 3 6 c'est pas ridicule et après
c'est 4 6 et 5,7 je crois et 4 6 4 6 5 7
6 2 4 6 3 6 4 6 d'accord voilà donc il
est quand même assez proche il prend pas
une culotté on va dire alors que il est
quand même en face un client donc c'est
vrai que c'est un courageux pour la
suite on va dire que c'est encourageant
mais il faut qu'il reste il faut pas
qu'il ait qu'il ne redescente rapide sur
le prochain tournoi qui est sur lequel
il va être il va être aligné ce qui
était dingue c'était d'ailleurs on
fondait quasiment les derniers espoirs
français sur en Arthur underkness
c'était le dernier représentant à ce
moment-là des français chez les hommes
sur le match premier set en effet comme
tu dis il est largement dominateur
service et on voit bien sur le deuxième
set c'est pas lui en plus sur ce match
là ce n'est pas Arthur qui joue moins
bien c'est son adversaire Fritz qui qui
prend le dessus et malheureusement il a
pas les il n'a pas les moyens de
d'élever son élever son niveau à ce
moment-là mais moi j'ai pas été déçu de
le de enfin pas été déçu sur le moment
je lui dis voilà l'autre est plus fort
c'est tout mais quand il a eu gagné le
premier set j'étais plein d'espoir je me
souviens j'étais oh purée c'est bon il
va y arriver parce que vraiment il
jouait la note à la perfection il y
avait aucune il y avait rien à dire et
ensuite c'est pas lui qui a fait des
erreurs c'est juste cette américain qui
est qui a joué qui avait son niveau
oui on va dire on va dire positif on va
dire
on va dire on espère encore pour Arthur
quoi simplement
pas déçu du match mais des sud du
résultat et puis voilà et puis en plus
bon c'était pas évident c'était le soir
en plus c'est toute la tous les
spectateurs ils étaient contre Fritz
donc ça sifflait ça hurlait ça c'était
quand même bon pas normal pas normal le
public n'a pas été même pendant pendant
toute la quinzaine
autour du public il y a une différence
énorme par rapport aux autres années et
en fin de compte en sifflant et en ça a
déconcentré aussi le genre français de
toute façon c'est obligé parce que mamie
ça se fait pas ce qui s'est passé c'est
pas c'est pas normal donc voilà donc
vous voyez comme je dis bon à voir
maintenant dans les prochains les
prochains tournois et puis le prochain
c'est
ATP d'airton game Bosch et défaite au
précise aussi qu'il y a donc il y avait
aucun français au troisième tour de
cette édition de Roland-Garros et c'est
la deuxième fois en deux ans après 2021
donc le triste bilan français
pour terminer sur cette thématique
tennis à Pauline déroulette qui est
effectuait son premier tournoi de
Roland-Garros en tennis fauteuil elle a
été tombée de la numéro 12 mondiale au
premier tour founou Meizu livinoise de
32 ans c'est incliné ensuite en quart de
finale contre la numéro 1 mondiale et
futur vainqueur du tournoi l'année
irlandaise diète de groots le score 600
64 en double la vie chinoise c'est mamie
c'est jusqu'en demi-finale avec sa
coéquipière Emmanuel moche une défaite
là encore contre les futurs vainqueurs
Lapeyre Kamiji mon jeune bah pour un
premier Roland-Garros j'ai envie de dire
qu'elle début génial là aussi respect
total et essayer c'est une c'est une
championne attachante par son par son
c'est fait de vie ils sont faits de vie
qui est qui l'a qu'il l'a conduite en
parce que c'est aussi un accident de la
route conduite en fauteuil de manière
assez tragique et elle s'en est relevé
elle en a fait une force c'est c'est un
c'est un justement une leçon de une
leçon de vie et quand ça commence à
quand ça commence à donner sportivement
en termes de résultats là aussi c'est
une belle promesse notamment pour les JO
pour les Jeux paralympiques avec avec
une championne porte drapeau qui va être
qui va être qui va être à suivre ce sera
l'une effectivement de nos l'un de nos
espoirs pour pour ces JO numéro 1
française d'ailleurs Pauline Déroulède
un avis messieurs
Djokovic par rapport ce respect parce
que bon il y a pas longtemps que la
commencé et je pense comme disait pierre
c'est le bon espoir pour les JO je dis
on avait encore s'améliorer j'en suis
persuadé elle a une force de caractère
incroyable incroyable et puis il faut
dire bah père en double et en simple
contre les
vainqueurs donc voilà c'est ce qu'il
faut se dire bravo on va poursuivre avec
du rugby 3 émissions si on parlait sport
pour ma part et trois thématiques rugby
vous l'aurez noté
vous restez Grégory il faut rester
justifie nous sommes à 86 jours de
l'ouverture de la Coupe du monde de
rugby en France l’engouement monte
dernière preuve en date ce mercredi 14
juin la commune des mureaux organisé une
journée drop en scène 20 équipes
d'enfants de 9 à 11 ans ont disputé le
tournoi le représentait chacune des 20
nations qualifiées pour le Mondial
événement partenariat avec le Stade
Français présence cet après-midi du
directeur général Thomas Lombard et on
va revenir à présent au 31 mai dernier
avec la présentation des médailles de la
compétition notamment au siège de la
région Île-de-France où nous étions
présents c'était à 100 jours très
exactement du lancement de la Coupe du
Monde une cérémonie en présence de
nombreux présidents de clubs franciliens
d'ailleurs les Yvelines on le rappelle
sont terre d'accueil de ces de deux pays
qui vont disputer la Coupe du monde à
Versailles sera le camp de base du Pays
de Galles et Croissy-sur-Seine
accueillera les îles les gars on va
écouter tout de suite Jacques Rivoal il
est-il Linois et président du comité
d'organisation de cette Coupe du Monde
représente plein de choses en fait ça
représente tout ce qu'on veut mettre
dans la Coupe du monde donc c'est
d'abord et cette coupe du monde donc ça
c'est une coupe du monde des territoires
donc vous avez sur cette médaille au
verso en fait les les le rubans de menu
qui est personnalisé à l'image de chacun
de chacune des villes hautes qui
accueillera la compétition et donc
illustre ce lien social ce lien qu'on
veut créer entre l'événement Coupe du
Monde et les territoires donc ça c'est
la première dimension la deuxième
dimension c'est insister sur le fait que
ces médailles ont été fabriqués à partir
de téléphone recyclés il y a eu 200 000
téléphones recyclés qui ont permis de
fabriquer les 1491 médailles donc ça
c'est la le témoignage qu'on veut
apporter à la société démontrer que
cette coupe du monde elle aura un impact
positif en particulier sur la sur la
production de l'environnement donc
aujourd'hui c'est un moment très
important parce qu'on dévoile ces
médailles et c'est le lancement
définitif de la dernière ligne droite de
la préparation de la Coupe du monde
chose très intéressante les médailles
j'écrivent le disait sont confectionnés
à partir de téléphone recyclés qui ont
été fournis par Orange 206 206 000
téléphones et c'est vraiment le
développement durable aussi que l'âge
c'est vraiment moi pour avoir été moi au
dévoilement des médailles à la Monnaie
de Paris le matin avant qui soit comment
au Conseil 1 au conseil régional c'est
c'est vraiment c'est c'est top je veux
dire j'ai vu tout le monde la mode Paris
tout le monde était vraiment et c'est
beau c'est un bon un bon signe voilà
c'est un bon clin d'oeil en plus et on
est content de pouvoir ça fait à peu
près 17000 je crois 17000 médailles en
comptant non mais 1700 plutôt et
quelques
temps les tous ceux qui participent et
les premiers deuxième et troisièmement
je veux dire comment ces médailles
c'est des médailles classiques mais
chose insolites quand même
souvent j'en pose des questions est-ce
que ce sont des vrais médailles d'or il
faut savoir qu'il y a que les médailles
des Jeux Olympiques qui sont en full en
or donc là c'est vrai que la le fait que
ce soit du matériau recyclé etc je pense
que elle ça apporte une saveur
supplémentaire à la à la médaille ouais
je pense que on peut être fier d'être
les premiers à mettre ce système en
place sur sur un sur un sport sur un
sport majeur c'est quoi votre état
d'esprit là à moins de 100 jours
maintenant de la compétition au taquet
au taquet
140 entre l'élection du nouveau
président aujourd'hui
Florian grill les nouveaux présidents de
l'accélération le siège était vacant a
depuis la démission de Bernard Laporte
donc c'est le président francilien
Florian grill qui maintenant le nouveau
président de la Fédération Française de
Rugby
je trouve que on en parle pas assez que
le fait que ces médailles aient été
fabriqués avec des téléphones recyclés
c'est dans la rue c'est dans l'air du
temps et et quand c'est le contraire on
nous on
nous casse les oreilles pour être poli
et là alors que là on devrait le mettre
en avant c'est une coupe du monde de
rugby qui se passe en France avec un
geste comme ça on aurait l'entendre un
peu plus souvent à la télévision et à la
radio c'est dommage il y a eu énormément
de festivités cette journée là son jour
son jour de l'ouverture Jacques Rivoal
qui est un éducateur versaillé qui est
en train de nos 8 à Versailles on est
mal rappelé le lundi et justement il y a
un grand nombre de de
faits qui sont qui sont organisés et de
points qui sont choisis pour
l'organisation de cette coupe du monde
pour laisser un héritage il y a un
héritage environnemental avec ce choix
de ce choix de médaille il y a un
héritage pour l'emploi aussi avec le
dispositif campus 2023 il y a une
volonté justement de de montrer le rugby
vraiment dans toute dans tous les
territoires d'ailleurs les 9 les 9
villes hautes ont été choisis justement
pour que tout le monde en profite et
toutes les équipes tournent de stade en
stade même l'équipe de France qui ne
joue jamais
au même stade ampoule si on a dans le
même stade donc il y a vraiment l'ail
oui on sent on sent le on sent la
pétanque et lexique l'excitation qui
monte et ça devrait être vraiment une
très très belle Coupe du Monde
félicitations en plus parce qu'à
Versailles on le disait camp de base
comme en 2007 il y avait l'Angleterre
qui était venu s'entraîner on se
souvient on a on a les images d'ailleurs
en archives il y avait une vraie liesse
populaire au commencement de Johnny
l'Angleterre de l'époque était un niveau
peut-être autre que celle que celui qui
est là en 2023 mais avec le Pays de
Galles qui est bon là pour le coup dans
une position sportive peut-être un petit
peu moins reluis ça fait ça fait malgré
tout une équipe une équipe bien connue
des amateurs de rugby et du tournoi des
6 nations présentes à Versailles et qui
va faire un certain nombre d'animations
dans la ville les hébergers quand même
les amis
de présentation des médailles a été
réalisée devant des présidents de clubs
yvelinois notamment ceux du Sky rugby et
du Rugby Club de Versailles ils vont
bientôt d'ailleurs disputer un tournoi
pour fêter la Coupe du Monde écoutez
c'est fabuleux on a une opportunité
fantastique celle de de nous réunir
autour de la balle au vol autour de
notre passion et il y a une chose qui
est intéressante à souligner c'est qu'on
plus localement notamment on va décliner
une mini-coupe du monde des écoles de
rugby chaque club a eu un parti rage au
sort le nom d'une équipe en l'occurrence
l'URSS 78 récupérer le l'Argentine donc
nous allons représenter l'Argentine et
tous les clubs des Yvelines ont adhéré à
cette idée de mini Coupe du monde qu'on
va rencontrer les Fidji etc enfin tenu
par d'autres clubs alors c'est une
magnifique opportunité oui alors
Versailles sera quelle équipe du coup
dans cette mini Coupe du monde avec
surprise sans surprise on aura le Pays
de Galles nous serons sous les yeux du
pédiatre puisque le Pays de Galles
arrive fin août à Versailles et on est
ravis puisque en 2007 on avait les
Anglais déjà Versailles ça c'était très
bien passé et là cette année avec
l'arrivée des des Gallois et ben on est
tous on est tous heureux et cette
manifestation aujourd'hui à 100 jours de
la Coupe du Monde nous fait vraiment
entrer dans le processus
dites nous en plus il va y avoir une
mini Coupe du monde entre les clubs
yvelinois du coup
un événement sportif qui qui à la fois
commémore commémore anime et puis
implique les différents clubs les
différents clubs des Yvelines il y a
aussi plein d'événements qui sont
organisés notamment la dès ce dès ce
week-end et lundi prochain la Coupe du
monde le trophée webbellis va être
présenté à la mairie lundi 19 pendant
toute la journée va être montré à tous
les versaillers et dimanche 18 à
l'occasion du tournoi 7 de cœur à
Porchefontaine donc le trophée qui sera
remis au vainqueur le 28 octobre qui
sera présenté à tous on espère que que
ce trophée ne va pas quitter la France
le 28 octobre avec une belle ambiance
pour y avoir déjà participé en tant que
journaliste en tant que
petite question monsieur est-ce que vous
pensez que ça va être une belle fête
cette coupe du monde de rugby Philippe
oui oui c'est une belle fête parce qu'en
plus bon il y a les il y a les matchs
mais il y a les fan zone faut penser et
ça se prépare bien moi je pour il y en a
une à comment à Paris
c'est pas assez
votre casier je sais plus et ben je veux
dire ça à la Concorde à la Concorde je
crois bien voilà Concorde je crois que
ça la Concorde et autres cadeaux il y a
plusieurs mais je pense que il y a
l'engouement on le sent que en plus là
avec la finale du Top 14 où c'est en
plus comment Toulouse et les deux
premiers du championnat les deux
meilleures équipes actuelles je pense
que que c'est pas mal c'est le dernier
vainqueur de la Champions Cup La
Rochelle
langouement ça se sent et c'est bien
après
un peu le premier match c'est quand même
France gros morceau France
Nouvelle-Zélande ce sera un peu comme en
97 ans comme 97 c'était France Argentine
aussi qui les avait retrouvé en en pour
la troisième place aussi que ça avait un
peu ils avaient perdu ils avaient perdu
ils avaient un peu je veux dire ah mais
bon là voilà
8 septembre au Stade de France la France
est aussi dans sa poule l'Italie
l'Uruguay et la Namibie qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de est-ce que ça va être une
belle fête sur cette thématique j'espère
moi j'habite la ville du rugby j'habite
à Marcoussis donc j'espère pouvoir en
profiter pleinement
non mais
comme c'est une ville rugby voilà c'est
une ville une ville de rugby même s'il y
aura pas grand monde mais voilà on va
avoir notre petite famille zone à nous
avec le club local qui qui va organiser
des choses c'est certain très actif le
club de Marcoussis donc oui je pense je
pense bien on pense bien en profiter et
puis et puis bah de toute façon comme
pour toutes les compétitions elle ne se
rappelle que si la France va au bout
bien sûr et c'est tout ce qu'on peut
leur souhaiter aussi parce que ben voilà
on a fait quand même deux très beaux
tournois les deux derniers tournois on a
fait deux très beaux tournois on a
besoin de Grand Chelem voilà on a je
pense qu'on a un effectif cette fois qui
qui peut aller qui peut aller au bout je
pense qu'on a peur de personne et
beaucoup ont peur de nous ce qu'on est
ce qu'on espère en fait c'est que ce
soit une très belle compétition et que
ça soit bon pour le développement du
rugby au niveau amateur au niveau
professionnel également et qu'on puisse
récupérer un grand nombre de licenciés
licenciés
qu'on espère aussi que le que le par
exemple le rugby féminin continue à se
développer à travers des affiches qui
seront quasiment toutes belles et dans
les stades dans les fans dans les télés
et dans les télés et à chaque à chaque
activité qui ne manqueront pas de d'être
organisé dans les villes très rapidement
juste une question est-ce que ce que là
je vais pas regarder est-ce que le
championnat continue pendant la
finalement oui on est le seul club on
est le seul la seule discipline de sport
collectif qui malheureusement je dis
bien malheureusement les années de coupe
du monde ils changeraient il y a
toujours le championnat d'Europe qui est
le tournoi des 6 nations chez nous et
bien le le championnat Top 14 la Coupe
du monde et il y aura toujours et il y
aura toujours le le le tournoi et
la démarrer autour du 17 du 17 septembre
avec le match de la France on précise
une date aussi un 21 juin Fabien Galtier
va dévoiler sa liste des 42 donc on
verra quels seront les forces en
présence pour l'équipe de France pour
cette coupe du monde de rugby voilà
c'est déjà la fin de ce SOP c'était ma
dernière à la présentation parce que la
prochaine fois il y aura le retour du du
Grand Mickaël el midoro et on va
terminer comme d'habitude par une petite
citation aujourd'hui je vous propose une
phrase prononcée par Raphaël Nadal qui
était le grand absent de ce Roland
Garros on rappelle 14 victoires sur la
terre battue parisienne ça grilleda nous
a manqué on gagne plus avec le cœur avec
la volonté qu'avec autre chose je vous
laisse méditer sur cela et je vous dis à
très vite sur TV 78
[Musique]